it was just a week ago that we were all
talking about Egypt i guess that thing
resolved itself so that was pretty good
we are on to syria it looks like we're
going to have a war possibly later this
afternoon possibly tomorrow we shall see
I don't want to make light of it though
a hundred thousand people have died in
conventional warfare and then suddenly
the chemicals have started to be being
used this week it looked like about a
thousand people but they've been used a
couple times before that and now there's
evidence of it and let's listen to the
human tree John Kerry discussing what
happened the indiscriminate slaughter of
civilians the killing of women and
children and innocent bystanders by
chemical weapons is a moral obscenity by
any standard it is inexcusable and
despite the excuses and equivocations
that some have manufactured it is
undeniable alright that's pretty much
the most emotional I've ever seen John
Kerry I don't quite understand the
distinction somehow it's okay if a
hundred thousand people died by bombs
and bullets but if they cough before
they die now were suddenly very upset so
let's just start with that is the red
line I mean Obama said the red line
thing so he sort of painted himself into
a corner here is the red line thing
because of chemical weapons this has
that now forced our hand here and we
have to do something well I think Obama
said it last year that if they use
chemical weapons that is that is a hard
line for the United States and probably
the rest of the world or the Western
world but I think it's very interesting
we talked about this earlier like you
said it's okay to slaughter and kill
women and children with bombs and
bullets and you know attacks and sniper
bullets and stuff like that but God
forbid they drop one of those bombs a
little bit of gas on it and kill people
in the middle of the night and then
suddenly now we're going to do something
two and a half years into this Civil War
so it's very difficult i was watching
some news last night I was watching some
old generals and some special operators
some strategy military strategists and
they're like so we're basically just
going to you know maybe throw some
Tomahawk missiles in there teach them a
lesson don't do you know don't drop
chemical bombs on your people again and
then curl out and not really do anything
don't put boots on I mean obviously we
probably have operative
in there and CIA people and stuff but as
far as like and we're announcing it to
the world I don't know I just don't I
don't I'd rather probably not do
anything and let them have their civil
war because what good is it going to do
for the United States or any of the
other countries around well you got got
to about five of the questions that I
want to get you but let I know let's
start though with with just the
distinction between which way people can
die do you find it more okay for a
hundred thousand people to die via
conventional warfare than chemical
warfare and again I'm not diminishing
object due date because I'm an American
I mean like why can't think you know
only a depraved animal would use
chemical weapons to kill someone why
can't they use a nice Christian depleted
uranium tip bomb like we use here how
about what they drop one of those bombs
we dropped on Japan that doesn't kill
women and children whatever they do want
to why don't they do that because we're
so much better it's so good to see John
Kerry gets so pissed off about
indiscriminate killing because you know
he served in Vietnam and if anybody
knows about indiscriminate killing its
John Kerry so this self-righteous
[ __ ] about chemical weapons like
because what he's really saying is if
you're gonna kill someone you better
blow their [ __ ] head off that's what
he's saying because if I go when I see a
body without blood on it I'm upset at
you and that's literally what he said
right during that press conference he
was actually saying if you would have
just destroyed the whole city that you
drop the chemicals in and then we
wouldn't have evidence of it we would
have been okay with that there you see
bodies laying there without blood on
them yeah and that upsets him and that
isn't that nuts yes yeah so this is all
great what this is is that we've been
committing so many war crimes for so
long and we've been doing so many
horrible things that we have to go look
we're not horrible because we're upset
about this right because we're doing
drone strikes right now in Yemen and in
other parts of the Middle East and an
innocent people are being killed and we
but that double taps yeah and you know
what that is right i do when they come
back again yet so that but that's a
whole separate issue so all right so
let's talk about so it looks like we're
going to war but yay we're not gonna
call it war because we're gonna do what
we did in Libya was like they called it
when they was an Xbox Kinect military
action is a strike from a couple boats
off the shore and overall go back out
into the water right so Obama who has
always said you know you have to have
congressional authorization we should go
three
un well doesn't look like we're going to
do it but Barack guess what your buddy
Joe Biden said about George W Bush doing
that and I'm eating through the
president the in accession to ward in
red without congressional approval I
will make it my business to impeach him
back
okay so there you have it that's Biden
in 2007 talking about george w bush but
now he's the vp of President Obama who's
about to do the exact same thing
hypocrisy what I mean I have a hard time
taking Biden seriously on anything he
says so now that he's piping in along
with John Kerry um yeah I would like it
to go to Congress because i think the
the Congress who are supposed to
represent the people which are us you
would hope that they'd have at least a
say in if we are going to I hope not
start a war but if we are going to
attack another country and and to do
what they say is gonna happen today or
tomorrow then you know I I think we
should go to Congress yet do you make
any distinction between just lobbing a
couple rockets so that's not war vs you
know something bigger that then would be
where I mean I'm pretty sure if Canada
lobbed a rocket into the United States
we would consider that an act of war
well al Qaeda didn't even use rockets
and we considered an act of war they
hijacked a couple planes so yes of
course you know of course it's the
squiggly line of whatever the [ __ ] we
want to be whenever we feel like it
whatever serves us right but shouldn't
we all be seriously upset with Obama
right now because he's the one that has
pushed this idea of everything has to go
through the UN which now it's very clear
that's not gonna happen and everything
has to go through Congress you know you
know yeah he's done a lot of things that
he's just pushed through himself as you
know that up into this point so it
doesn't surprise me that he's doing that
now yeah so final question is is this
actually Obama's fault because the red
line thing not that what the killing is
not his fault there but because he
really did box us into a corner where he
said this is not send off the bombs he
could not order the Tamil Castle shipped
yeah yeah I mean listen I don't want to
go to war I don't think we should be
doing anything that fine but can he not
he said oh if we use chemical weapons
what would what would you think of Obama
that would you think he's a week
president because he said I'm gonna send
out we're gonna do something if chemical
weapons I think that's a thinking I
think that's the thinking in Washington
etc
nine and you crossed it and now if he
doesn't do anything the credibility of
the administration well that's that
legit that late argument he's got
credibility issues anyways but it was
the thing about those Peace Prizes date
nobody ever tries to win a second one
yeah perfect perfect ending to this and
yeah Obama got the nobel peace prize
before he was president this is now
going to be his second war without going
to Congress for